it's a quarter to midnight you're
watching Sky News a very warm welcome to
those of you just joining us from Sky
showcase we're counting down the final
few minutes of 2021 with our
correspondence across the UK and we'll
take you right the way up to midnight
and Beyond we're in London Big Ben will
chime and fireworks are expected let's
get more on how New Year's Eve will be
celebrated tonight around the country
Katarina vertotsi is here in London for
us we've also got James Matthews and
Edinburgh and Dan Whitehead and Cardiff
but let's talk to Katarina first uh
Catherine in no official event tonight
but we know that there are going to be
some fireworks some light shows and some
drones tell us more
yes so London's Mercedes Khan earlier
this afternoon promised the best
fireworks the best display he said it
would be a spectacular 30 minutes but
with the big caveat that they didn't
want people to come down to London's
famous landmarks they wanted people to
stay at home in their living rooms and
watch it instead it's there he said that
people would be able to get the best
view but that has created a bit of
confusion down here at the River Thames
where typically this is where you'd see
that iconic fireworks display that would
go on for 10 minutes at least set to
music so some people expecting to see
fireworks like that we're not expecting
that bells and whistles show however
lots of people asking us where's the
best place to get the best vantage point
quite simply the guidance is that people
are not meant to be going looking for
those firework spots and as I said I've
been asked to stay at home on their sofa
and watch it instead Central London
although it is open this evening bars
pubs and restaurants across the capital
are open there are no restrictions that
were forcing them to close unlike I'm
sure we'll hear from James is in the
case in Scotland here they are open but
they are much quieter than usual and the
river which on a normal New Year's Eve
with the normal fireworks display would
be you know 10 12 rows deep at some
points uh plenty of room lots of people
walking past us at the moment so things
pretty quiet here as I say we're still
waiting to see exactly what might happen
behind me is The Shard and Millennium
Bridge some people starting to gather
around those points expecting maybe some
sort of display to happen whether that's
part of the fireworks maybe that's part
of the lights or the Drone show is yet
to be seen But London will put a good
face on it London's mayor says it'll be
better than Sydney I was speaking to our
colleagues over at Sky News Australia a
little earlier today and they said they
would wait to see they said that the
Cricket Ash's performance if anything to
go by they still thought Australia's
display would top that here in London
but let's give another 15 minutes and
see shall we I think they were just
being polite Katarina but Big Ben is
going to the Big Ben's going to chime as
well he's been quiet for the last four
years we've had occasional events where
it's been able to chime using this
mechanical chiming mechanism but we're
going to hear it again in Midnight
aren't we
yeah the Big Ben will have its first
proper unveiling really since uh that
iconic clock face was having some vital
repair work to it that have been crowds
gathering around Big Ben in Parliament
Square we're across the river from South
Bank where you have a beautiful view of
Millennium bridge and the globe and the
shop where some people are hoping to
capture glimpse of what we're told as I
said London's mayor will says will be a
spectacular display
um but I think it is fair to say it will
be a little bit more muted I mean we had
the Prime Minister Boris Johnson today
saying that he was going into 2022 a lot
more optimistic than he was at this
point last year but people you speak to
um you know it doesn't feel like it the
normal New Year's Eve celebration they
just aren't the volume of people some
people choosing just to follow that
guidance and to stay at home and watch
whatever may happen on their TV and as I
said bars pubs clubs are open but
nowhere near as full as you might expect
it so prime minister giving that note of
optimism London mayor promising the best
display ever reality on the ground
perhaps not sharing exactly the same
sense of Celebration but hopefully
optimism as we head into the new year
okay Catherine we'll be back to you in a
short while but let's cross to James
Matthews who's up in Edinburgh for us
and James the official hogmanay
celebrations were canceled of course
it's a massive money spinner for the
City of Edinburgh isn't it what is the
atmosphere like there on the streets
this evening
the atmosphere Jane is like Princess
Street on I don't know On Any Given
weekday I'd say around 7 30 in the
morning with people coming and going
like they do during the week on their
normal commute there are there is human
traffic but you know it's passing
traffic they are on their way to
something else because there's nothing
happening here in edinburgh's Golden
Mile normally 75 000 people are crammed
in here that are bands playing that are
fireworks from the castle up there you
can see it a little blue tonight
normally come to midnight or it's a huge
spectacle which we are used to aren't we
but not this year they had reduced
numbers to 30 000 but even then Nicola
surgeon put that clamp of 500 on outdoor
events therefore edinburgh's hogmany
events were kicked into next year and
that's not just a street party uh it's
the party in the gardens Princess Street
Gardens the Torchlight procession and
the lady Duke when everybody piles into
uh the fourth or fourth on New Year's
Day so you know there are people around
I have to say Jane uh we feel a bit
guilty here every time we settle the
camera on a tripod there are people who
come up and say are you setting up for
the fireworks because you know the word
doesn't necessarily filter down to
people who've arrived in town for the
fireworks and there's no doubt people
have come abroad they have booked bought
tickets
and either not expected the cancellation
or have come for the holiday anyway
let's speak to a few of the people who
are in the city in the vicinity we're
just at the foot of Castle Street Castle
Street that looks on to the castle some
young girls got to speak to us here
hello girls
[Music]
tell me
um what do you think of being here
tonight because it's it's normally
really busy but it's quiet
I think
um
to see the fireworks yeah and what do
you think girls and we think that um
that um it should be better for next
year as well
more fun for everyone to have yeah do
you have a party do you like the
fireworks and all that yeah well I hope
we can learn something better for you
next year might see you here next year
eh okay thank you very much indeed now
uh let's go and find um hero he's from
Turkey now you have a you have a story
hello you're best here but but you are
not no yes
six months ago six months ago yeah you
came here for the big expecting the big
Edinburgh firework party yeah the first
time I think yeah
and what do you make of this are we just
talking about for history here but
tonight you know we worry about for if I
walk and but
no savings before covet 19. yeah but we
will see first time this year yeah well
first time next year maybe yeah yeah I
don't know yeah
what do you think yeah you don't speak
that your English isn't it's better than
my turkey Turkish do you Turkish no no
sadly not uh what do you think of this
very beautiful very beautiful yes yes
all right next year hopefully yeah we'll
see let's go and see if we can speak to
some other people
um here's a couple of guys hello ads how
you doing you you base locally or are
you well
we normally come down Edinburgh as well
all right yeah what were you expecting
today
fireworks
did nobody tell you they were canceled
or the canceled no actually no one
pulled this uh we just kind of to be fun
it doesn't really affect us anyway I
don't know yeah as long as I'm making
money that's the happiest part of the
year I associate all of us what do you
think of this mate a bit quieter than
you expected well well I'm disappointed
that you told me that the fireworks is
canceled yes
but it's all right at least we came down
it's still it's still a nice way people
are around each other so it's not
actually that bad even if I've covered
so but I can only just get back from
here all right well thanks for your time
Lads and enjoy the rest of the night if
you can cheers
um so there you go some people knew it
was canceled some did not but people
seem quite happy just to gather and have
some kind of communal experience I
suppose hello hi we're from Sky News
we're live hello um what'd you make up
all this it's a bit quieter than usually
uh yeah it's really busy we're done from
an Aberdeen moves meant to be at the
street party tonight but it's canceled
obviously so a bit got it yeah yeah
because you know it's normally party
central you know it kind of means a lot
to people who come here for the event
especially for being the capital city it
would usually be really busy yeah so
I will sorry we'll let you down this
year I know but along next time so well
there you go uh James same old Edinburgh
same old beautiful castle take a last
look uh Blue tonight is a suggestion
that we might have the one o'clock gun
come midnight though we've heard a
relatively soft buying in the hours
leading up to midnight so maybe that's
the plan but certainly far short of the
uh the midnight spectacular that we
normally get here in Scotland's capital
yeah I think I caught a hint of a
bagpipe just there behind you James
James Matthews there a spreading joy and
cheer on the streets of Edinburgh and
Let's cross now to Dan Whitehead who's
in Cardiff for us and and Dan they had
big plans there as well didn't they
yeah it's similar actually to James
we've had to break the news to a few
people who've come down to Cardiff Bay
uh that the fireworks are indeed off no
official fireworks being put on uh by
the Welsh government or indeed Cardiff
Council uh tonight
um a few people here but it's really
really quiet right across the Welsh
Capital tougher rules in Wales compared
to England certainly the nightclubs are
all closed the bars are sit down service
Only Rule of six remember that well
that's backing Force here in Wales and
it is having a bit of a dampening impact
we were inside one of the bars chained
to people who've decided to go out uh
tonight and they basically said they're
going to try and make the most of it
really try and have a good evening but
there's not much atmosphere we were in a
couple of the the biggest bars in
Cardiff that usually would be absolutely
heaving tonight and one of them we
counted eight people in the entire uh
mega bar essentially really at prism
nightclub another huge nightclub here in
Cardiff that would be expecting a really
big night that has also shut its doors
so a difficult evening for the
businesses here and actually what some
people in what else have decided to do
is essentially free the country we were
over at Bristol at Temple Meads the main
railway station in Bristol earlier today
and every single train coming in from
Cardiff to an hour had plenty of people
from Swansea from Port Talbot from
Newport from Cardiff are all coming over
to ensure that they can have a really
big night you might be able to hear some
bagpipes uh that James hasn't sent those
down that is a restaurant down here
which is making the most of it and
having a bagpiper
um but people have traveled over to
Bristol traveled over to England where
the nightclubs are open where there's no
restriction on how many people you can
meet and they had booked hotels and
airbnbs last minute to try and ensure
that they get a very long and big
celebration lots of groups of friends
had come from a ride over at Wales for a
night over in England in but for those
who've come down to Cardiff Bay here and
up in the main city center the bars are
pretty empty and as I say the nightclubs
are shut so over in Newport as well we
spoke to one bar owner who had a big
black tie glitter ball evening planned
and this morning decided to shut
entirely he didn't want to put the staff
through the responsibility of having to
tell customers not to stand up not to
hug people not to go over to other
tables at midnight and they thought
that's what New Year's all about we
don't want to have our staff to tell our
customers they can't do that so they
decided to cancel the whole event
entirely which is pretty sad news here
in uh Cardiff but of course the Welsh
government taking a more cautious
approach perhaps as the Omicron numbers
continue to rise here in Wales but now
of course as we approach midnight people
we'll be stopping the few people here
will be stopping to bring in the New
Year Dan thanks very much and also James
up in Edinburgh let's return to Katarina
who's in London uh Katarina not very
long to go now or a few people coming
out and drips and drabs to Market
um there are a few people coming out and
it looks like this is behind me and like
you see the top of The Shard building
and there's some sort of countdown that
seems to be on a bit of a loop a
countdown from ten to one and then back
uh 210 so we might start to see
something happening a lot of people
pausing and if we want to maybe just uh
Zoom a little towards the end of the
bridge you can see how people are really
trying to get any Vantage Point not
really knowing exactly where is best to
go they're sort of hedging their bets
really and there's quite a big group of
people who are now at the corner of the
River Thames they've got a view not only
of the child building but a millennium
Bridge because
as I said no official display people
have been told not to come down but of
course curiosity gets the best of a lot
of people and people just want to see
where they're a good place to see
whatever it might be here thanks
Katarina
if you just tune them away it is almost
midnight and you are watching Sky News
we are counting down the last few
moments of 2021 this is the picture in
London where some fireworks are expected
Big Ben's also expected to chime let's
pause to welcome in the new year
[Applause]
wow that's
[Applause]
awesome
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
Chimes ring out around us
is that it
is
[Music]
let's go there
[Music]
you go back to Catherine
thank you
foreign
lights and some fireworks
um not as entirely spectacular as some
might have expected but it was meant to
be canceled in its entirety initially
Let's cross back to Katarina vitotsi
he's down on the backs of the Thames for
us uh not far from The Shard Katarina
which has been its tip has been glowing
different colors we saw the countdown
there and we heard the bonds of Big Ben
but be spectacular and the light and the
fireworks they're being spread out
across London aren't they Katarina
yeah and I think that is something very
tactical by organizers they wanted to
avoid large groups of people people in
in one place and I think though as you
might be able to hear behind me there is
still little bits of fireworks happening
in the corner of the Thames where we are
now just in front of The Shard and
there's lots of people who are still
waiting and Gathering wanting to see a
little bit of the spectacular that they
were promised at least on TV at least
but
spectacular but brief I would say at
this corner out of the River Thames but
you never know there might be a little
bit more up London sleeve for this
corner of the river but The Shard still
spectacular with it sort of being lit up
and that wonderful brief but beautiful
blaze of fireworks on the Millennium uh
Bridge behind me but as we say this
fireworks spectacular spread out across
various London landmarks not
concentrated in that one particular area
as we've seen in New Year's Eve's past
and a celebration a 30-minute
spectacular that Sadiq Khan promised
spread out remembering events of the
party but also looking to 2022 with a
bit more optimism
and as you were saying earlier Katarina
of course because of restrictions London
is a great deal quieter than it would
ever be it's it's not the case that
there are lots and lots of people down
in London at the moment they're all just
staying inside the bars and the
restaurants are up are quite deserted
yeah we've had teams my colleague was in
central London in SoHo this evening and
there were plenty of empty seats and
restaurants bars busy ish but certainly
not the volume that you'd expect a
normal New Year's Eve points along the
river where as you say on a normal year
you'd expect deep deep rows of people
waiting and waiting for many hours I
mean I covered a New Year's Eve
celebration I think three years ago and
we had to be there at 6 PM just in order
to get that Prime spot but now you know
people turning up five minutes before
hoping to get a glimpse of New Year's
ease that felt maybe a little bit more
normal I think in these uncertain times
a bit of a more normal New Year's Eve or
something that everyone was looking
forward to but certainly you know we
were told the official event was
canceled we were told there would be
something no one knew exactly what it
was the crowds that were standing here I
mean I don't know if you can see behind
me there are still people waiting and
looking just to see if there's anything
further happening on this part of the
river it doesn't appear like there will
be a lot of things looking like they're
happening actually slightly further down
towards tower bridge and the shards
still setting off a few beams of light
but certainly not the New Year's Eve
fireworks that we you know have known
from times past something slightly
different something slightly more in
keeping with the times that we all find
ourselves in and even though we might
not you know have that great big Grand
display certainly something very special
very resonant about hearing the Chimes
of Big Ben at midnight on New Year's Eve
I think for many people that is the
sound of New Year's Eve and whatever
happens with the fireworks that sound
Remains the Same
Katarina thanks very much let's return
to James Mackies who's up in Edinburgh
for us at James the last time we spoke
to you were joined by some other
youngsters who are up past their bedtime
just like you are what is the mood like
has there been anything to to Mark the
passing of one year into the next Where
You Are
yeah yeah I mean the mood's good
actually Jenna was a great deal of warm
Catherine is talking about the sound of
New Year's Eve well we found the sound
of hogmany I'll step out a shot so you
can see the young man laying on the sore
piece of entertainment on edinburgh's
Golden Mile tonight
and uh good luck to them too you can see
the crowd if we just pan to the right
see the kind of crowd they're Scarlet I
would say there's several hundred
several hundred people in the West End
of Princeton Street tonight many of them
uh were expecting fireworks actually I
know that because that's what some
people have told me it didn't realize
there had been a a cancellation let's
speak to a couple of people who are
gathered here today hello where have you
come from
um aberdeenshire what do you make of
this it's a bit quieter as we came down
for the hog money party but got canceled
or disappointed so did you buy tickets
yes did you know it was canceled before
you came down uh well we did but when we
came down everyone else was still going
on and the day became everything else
got canceled oh well sorry you've had a
quiet night what do you think
[Music]
uh gentleman by the name of P Irvin I
don't know if you recognize our name but
he is the man who for many years
organized edamorous hogmany and made it
what it became very busy
there's a lot of good humor about
tonight a lot of wrong jokes uh P Irvin
here you are hello Pete Scott live on
Sky News again you are the man for many
years the guru of Edinburgh and
everything awards are hogberry
well you also were a very important guy
as far as televising Adam oh well thank
you but enough of this mutual
appreciation yeah tell me
um what do you make of this this is nice
actually a few hundred people it's quiet
it's quite warm people are feeling good
but covered and this isn't what
Edinburgh has been is normally it's a
new year
well I'm here because you know I haven't
been here for a couple of years actually
and I just thought it'd be great to come
up tone as it were great City really
mild great night I really uh convivial
code not too many people and uh actually
I'm really enjoying being here so I
don't I don't find it all odd it's
covered times this is how it should be
no question that this should have been
canceled
um as it was in London they're not doing
fireworks and eventually we're not doing
fireworks either so I think that's the
right thing to be doing yeah I don't
think this will continue you see you're
enjoying this tonight what are you
enjoying
well I'm enjoying that I could just come
up here and walk around and not get
hustled by anybody and um and not be
responsible for anything here you know
and and and just to enjoy it the moment
of being here in my city thanks very
much indeed uh Pete there is that
freedom in not having the responsibility
just a happy New Year you're live on Sky
News yeah oh happy New Year I'm happy
New Year to you okay then just to
celebrate New Years here in Edinburgh oh
wow and uh and what do you want what do
you think of this a bit quieter than
yeah quite quiet we are a little bit sad
but yeah we we don't have like to say
anything but it's nice to be here yeah
and celebrate here she coming from from
Sweden but I am from here from Edinburgh
oh yeah normally from Morocco but I live
from Edinburgh yeah fantastic but we
have all our family to come see the
fireworks but it was like shorter but
nice yeah you were very sure it wasn't
it was the one o'clock gone out midnight
yeah happy New Years for you and for
everyone happy New Year to you too hello
there sir where are you from where are
you from India India what do you make of
all this yeah it's amazing but like we
are waiting for some five firecrackers
but it's not there so yeah we are a bit
um embarrassed for that but it's fine
it's amazing Indian
bro it's amazing
glad you're enjoying it sorry about the
fireworks what do you think of this yeah
we really uh we came here a little not
all only us like so many people come
here uh to enjoy something like if it's
not in Scotland everywhere else uh
somebody peoples to enjoy something
they're new here but that that that's
our uh aim to at least
enjoy something but nothing happened
thanks very much I hope you enjoy the
rest of your time let's
let's take a walk through the crow Let's
Walk This Way walk ahead of me and uh
you want the dancing has started at
least one the uh stray ahead just to the
right of the piper
[Music]
I wonder if this young man actually I
wonder if this young man will have a
quick challenge
to Brick into his pipeline
follow me
sorry that's really rude stopping you
playing the fights we'll we'll keep it
brief you are the one piece of
entertainment at Edinburgh Spencer
Street tonight uh why why why uh
I enjoy playing fights and I come up
here a bit during the big thing here a
bit during Christmas so I thought I
might come off again yeah well your
music is fantastic and being enjoyed by
several hundred people here tonight
from around the world that must make you
feel good yeah yeah yeah
um yeah I get to know people actually
like my music yeah great well yeah crack
on me uh thank you very much indeed and
um well providing the servers that many
people in Princeton Street tonight uh
have welcomed let's take one last look
at the crowds several hundred as I say
missing the firework we're enjoying
Scotland's capital city the castle high
up to the left as you can see lit
blue for Scotland but we're not seeing
the fireworks we normally see in
Scotland's capital tonight maybe next
year James thanks so much and on the
subject of blue we must apologize for
the rather colorful language that you
may have picked up on a little bit of
James's broadcast earlier we can't
control the crowds unfortunately some of
those out there on the streets seem to
have no regard to that there are young
children very nearby but James Matthews
soaking up the atmosphere in Edinburgh
for us Let's cross from Edinburgh to
Cardiff and Dan Whitehead is there and
down at Cardiff Bay it was going to be a
smashing night wasn't it there were
fireworks planned there was a lot of
celebrations Jolly quiet though
pretty quiet quiet we said there were no
fireworks then of course there were some
fireworks but no official displays they
go uh there's some people who've brought
their boats down to the bay and they
sell off a little bit of a display I
would say a couple of hundred people uh
had gathered down here in in Cardiff Bay
to to watch uh those modest fireworks
and they've all uh dispersed but it
really has been a a quiet night right
across the Welsh Capital that really is
the story from the clubs where the
takeaways are and the bars walking
around there this of course should be an
absolutely uh heaving night for
cardiff's nighttime economy but they
were dead this evening we were counting
on one hand the number of people in some
of the biggest bars and the nightclubs
are shut uh completely they're not
allowed to open here in Wales and
there's tougher rules as well in the
bars the rule of six and uh only being
served at the table we can just have a
little look around here behind me here
there's just a handful of people now in
the restaurant down here in Cardiff Bay
May of course have been busy tonight
they've been fully booked but they've
had to have reduced capacity in a lot of
cases and down here in uh the bay area
by the Millennium Center this would
usually be heaving with thousands of
people as you say who would have planned
to have come down and celebrated at the
new year coming in with the fireworks
but those crowds that simply are not
here this evening and what a lot of
people have done in Wales is left the
country in and fled over the border to
England not just down here in South
Wales wrexham to Chester but certainly
going across from Cardiff to Newport
over to Bristol we were over in Bristol
earlier today and every single train
that was coming into Bristol Temple
meets had plenty of young Welsh groups
of friends from Swansea from Port Talbot
from Cardiff from Newport coming for the
nights over in England where of course
the restrictions are fewer people can go
nightclubbing they can meet up with as
many people as they want to and so they
decided not to stay in Wales for the New
Year celebrations and instead head over
to England so that's what a lot of young
people did but for those who did go out
here in Wales tonight in the bars we
were chatting to them and they were
saying it really doesn't have the
atmosphere that they were hoping for but
they're going to make the most of it and
try and have a good night but certainly
the area is clearing now of course what
the Welsh government did want to do with
Omicron cases Rising is to see the big
crowds Gathering down here so that
public message has worked and we have
not seen despite it being incredibly
mild of course across the country and
certainly down here in Carla tonight
very mild temperatures which of course
would eventually it would used to be
heaving down here but people have heeded
the advice stayed at home to watch any
form of celebrations and not gone out in
the city not good though for the economy
because some of the bars and the owners
and the managers that we've been
speaking to actually decided not to
Simply open we were in Newport a couple
of hours ago where the pub uh the uh
chain Pub there had had been planning a
big uh glitter ball event they decided
to Simply shut their doors they didn't
want to put their staff through the
pressure of having to tell customers at
midnight you've got to stay seated don't
get up don't go and hug that person and
say happy new year and
um they said that was going to be too
difficult for their staff so they
decided to shut the pub entirely crowds
here or what what uh or what was a few
Crowds Are now starting to disperse it's
been a very quiet night in the Welsh
capital
it certainly has Dan thanks very much
well let's take you back to London and
we can refresh our memories as to how
some of the fireworks went we've got
some footage now of the fireworks that
were set off at Greenwich let's take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
next station is Wembley exit here for
football's greatest moments
the men did us proud in the Euros last
year can the women go on better
players take the knee United in their
stance Against Racism
[Music]
again and again they stream forward
looking for an opening deathless chicken
[Applause]
is brilliant that is
wild the country goes wild we hope to
see you in London for the UEFA women's
euros
2022 will be huge for sport well those
pictures courtesy of BBC events showing
us how we marked it in London let's see
how people around the world have been
celebrating the arrival of the new year
including in Hong Kong Australia and
Greece
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]